it's the chicago white sox and the
cleveland indians in a split double
header and the white sox with one win
will clinch the american league central
crown here in 2021 aaron zavala who is
out there on the mound they will be the
indian starting pitcher tonight and
they're going to try and stop these
white sox from clinching today today's
one of those days you come to the
ballpark and you think i'm about to see
something really fun and really
interesting
that falls cracked into right center
field straw is back at the wall hey a
good start
tim anderson rushes up the first run of
the ball game and the sox have a
one-nothing lead if you're looking for
omens
that is a shining one here in the first
inning and if you're
doubtful at all about how lively the
park is going to be with the wind
blowing toward right center don't be
it's going to fly that way
three-man ship right side of the infield
for cleveland nice
way out in front of that curveball and
somali strikes him out one down
ronaldo on for his eighth saturday's
three and three era and even three he's
actually had very good luck against the
indians
check swing he did go strike three
alex tosi over at first base has a
strikeout
but now here is luis robert who is at
this moment one of the toughest outs in
the league and that ball is absolutely
crushed
man oh man luis robert
makes it a two-nothing sox lead
in a majestic way
that's wind no wind
cool temperatures no temperatures
that ball is long gone a towering fly
ball
makes it a two to nothing game
that'll bring up eloy jimenez one and
two
that ball is annihilated
and another chance to bring him home
it's three nothing socks
eloy they're gonna go back-to-back
it's a solo home run jackpot and a party
in the dugout
we'll take that
leori garcia to right field and that's a
base hit three straight hits for the sox
two left the ballpark and on this road
trip coming into this game the sox had
two home runs during the whole road
swing here's cesar there goes garcia and
cesar tags this ball into right
garcia didn't read it well off the bat
and he could have had third instead
he ends up at second base
so far boys are tattooing savali
in the air again right field zimmer is
back at the track oh he did it again
tim anderson
wants to do it all by his lonesome
and the sox are pouring it on on what
looks more and more
like clinch day
now if you're gonna have a party
you might as well blow out the budget it
is six to nothing now robert who cranked
the first pitch of the inning a towering
home run to left
robert catapults this ball to center
field straw is back at the track and
luis robert clangs that one off the
fence
and he's got himself a long ball rbi and
the sox have a seven nothing lead
sox have knocked out the starter savali
7-0 they'll bring up the catcher austin
hitches
the 3-2 pitch
is boomed high in the year deep left
field jimenez back he's out of room it's
out of here
ninth home run of the year for austin
hedges and the indians get on the board
here in inning number three
his fourth home run of the year against
the white sox
here's bobby bradley bradley struck out
his first time up
rocked deep center
back and going a home run for bobby
bradley
[Applause]
second solo homer of the game for
cleveland home run number 15 on the year
for bradley and it's 7-2
well he picked on a nice fastball to hit
and he did not miss it
lopez gives up his eighth home run
second of the game
that felt good and right into that big
old glove again you can't mess with that
one tony larussa finally making his way
out of the dugout took him a while but
he's gonna make a pitching change here
with one down in the fourth
and the indians cutting into the lead at
seven to two
and he gives way to garrett crochet
that's a ground ball much needed
hernandez's turn is right there and it's
a double play
six to four to three garrett crochet
gets a huge twin killing and we go off
to the fifth
lefty lefty owen two bummer two jimenez
that is strike three right down the gut
and he didn't know what it was
tim from shortstop
five infielders take the unders so far
socks are up seven to two ready to
clinch the division
one two
cesar right side that's a three for
three
the cesar hernandez revenge game has
gone well
that is through the left side tim
anderson's third hit this afternoon
[Applause]
and the sox have two on
runners roll
3-2 to grand all
strike three called he got caught
peeking
a new pitcher in the ball game greg
kimbrough comes on 60th time
runner goes throw down to second is a
good one and yes got him zimmer is out
at second base
that ball hummed in there
it was a perfect throw he gets rid of
the ball quickly and this is a pretty
good throw
dan bellino on the call and that's going
to be it tim got him quick tag got the
body before the leg and that is
a first out
they could have the bases loaded right
now while bradley zimmer was thrown out
trying to steal earlier in the frame so
they've got two on with two out and you
chang coming up
here's the pitch swinging a soft ground
ball to anderson he'll throw to first
kimbrell had to work hard but he didn't
give up a run
and we go to the seventh inning in this
shortened contest
liam hendricks trying to close it out
for the sox today liam works out of the
stretch the right-hander on a 1-1
popped in the air
right-hand side this is garcia over to
make the catch for out number one
to third monkata of bobble it would have
been a game ending double play instead
the drama bubbles for another moment or
two
seven to two white sox bottom of the
seventh one out away the batter mile
straw runner third here's the one twos
hendricks got him and for the first time
since 2008
sox fans will see home playoff
baseball the chicago white sox
are winners
of the al
central
you